Speaker 1: I briefly talked about this on
our livestream.
Tucker Carlson, Fox News propagandist, is
now increasingly signal boosting a baseless
and wild conspiracy that FBI agents were behind
in terms of planning or even participants
in the January 6th Trump riots.
And we're going to look at a couple clips
of this, starting with Tucker Carlson two
days ago.
Listen to him lay this out.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 4: But strangely, some of the key
people who participated on January 6th have
not been charged, right.
Look at the documents the government calls
those people unindicted coconspirators.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that potentially every single
case they were FBI operatives
Speaker 1: understand the language there.
Tucker says it means that potentially in every
single case they were FBI operatives.
This is baseless.
He's not saying I have any evidence that FBI
operatives planned the January six riots or
participated in them.
We know about the issue of off duty law enforcement
participating in the riots.
We know about the issue of current and former
military being overrepresented in the riots.
But Tucker is alleging something else.
I'm going to be honest.
I don't think Tucker believes this.
I think Tucker is doing it because he knows
his audience is going to eat it up.
Take a listen to what else he says.
Speaker 4: Really in the capital on January
6th, right, for example, one of those unindicted
coconspirators is someone government documents
identify only as person two, according to
those documents, person to state in the same
hotel room as a man called Thomas Cauldwell
and Insurrectionist, a man alleged to be a
member of the group, the Oath Keepers person
to also, quote, stormed the barricades at
the Capitol on January 6th.
Speaker 1: Understand that there are countless
reasons why in this court document some other
coconspirators would be referred to as person
to or person three, including that they are
not.
If you look at Person Tu's court documents,
if there are such documents, the people in
this case might be referred to as person one,
two, three, four, whatever.
There could be other reasons to maintain the
privacy of those individuals.
They may not yet have been charged because
the cases are still being built, but none
of that signals any reason to believe that
they are FBI agents
Speaker 4: alongside Thomas Caldwell.
Yeah, the government's indictments further
indicate the KOBU, by the way, is the sixty
five year old man is dangerous.
Insurrectionist was led to believe there would
be a, quote, quick reaction force also participating
on January 6th.
That quick reaction force, Caldwell was told,
would be led by someone called Person three
who had a hotel room and an accomplice with
them.
Speaker 1: Now, understand that when it's
convenient and they do this all the time,
when it's convenient, Tucker and others will
cite the insurrectionists and not even question
their credibility.
But in other times, when it's not convenient,
they will immediately say, you can't trust
these insurrectionist rioters.
First of all, they're accused of crimes.
So they'll say anything they can to get out
of trouble here because Tucker is ginning
up another one of these furious conspiracies
for his audience.
These very same defendants are completely
trustworthy in what they say.
Speaker 4: But wait, here's the interesting
thing.
Person to in person.
Three were organizers of the riot.
The government knows who they are, but the
government has not charged them.
Why is that?
You know why?
They were almost certainly working for the
FBI.
So FBI,
Speaker 1: remember, there is no evidence
of that, that he has presented none.
You have to know how to listen to what there
is no evidence of.
Speaker 4: Operatives were organizing the
attack on the Capitol.
Speaker 1: There's no evidence on
Speaker 4: January six, according to government
documents.
Speaker 1: No.
So now he's being tricky.
Now he's saying the individuals we are not
naming in the documents were organizers.
But Tucker is the one saying they were FBI
agents.
And Tucker is now building on the first minute
of this segment as evidence for the second
minute.
Speaker 4: And those two are not alone in
all.
Revolver News reported that there are, quote,
upwards of twenty unindicted coconspirators
in the oath keeper indictments, all playing
various roles in the conspiracy who have not
been charged for virtually the exact same
activities and in some cases much, much more
severe activities as those named alongside
them in the indictment.
Speaker 1: So understand that, first of all,
Revolver News is a right wing media outlet
of questionable credibility.
Number two, still no evidence presented that
these are folks from the FBI.
So then the next day, Tucker doubles down
and actually brings on Darren B'Day from Revolver
News.
And again, it's this is how you propagandize
to ignorant people
Speaker 4: Congress because they oppose the
regime.
Even Vladimir Putin is not doing that.
And there's a former assistant director, the
FBI, calling for it on television and no one
noticed, senator, rounding people up.
How about rounding up the FBI operatives that
rioted on January six one?
Speaker 1: So now he is without evidence.
Just assuming this from his previous segment.
It's and remember, no evidence has been presented
and
Speaker 4: identify the guy who shot actually
Babbitt to death.
This is crazy.
And we should resist it.
Drumbeating heads up revolver news.
Here we go to see him tonight.
Darren, thanks so much for coming on.
It sounds like according to this, I have to
say, a remarkable piece that you just put
up late last night starting at midnight, that
the FBI was organizing the riots of January
6th.
Speaker 1: So to Tucker, it sounds that way
because of this article.
Now, the guy who wrote the article is here.
Let's listen.
Speaker 4: Well, yes, it certainly suggests
that possibility, and I'm
Speaker 1: hearing from it suggests the possibility,
I don't even know that we need to listen to
more.
It suggests the possibility.
This is all a house of cards with no evidence
Speaker 5: people, that this is the most important
and the darkest investigative piece they've
seen in years.
Speaker 1: But the American people, the people
who support revolver news are the ones telling
Darren Beadie that.
So we don't even need to go further.
And you guys, if you know me, the FBI is not
uniquely good or uniquely bad.
Intelligence agencies in the United States
and in other countries sometimes do things
we would call good and sometimes do things
that we call bad.
That is not about that.
It is not about we now love the FBI.
We now love the CIA.
It's this is all based on nothing.
Tucker story is based on Darren Betis story.
And Darren Beattie shows up and says, well,
there is the suggestion that it is possible
that FBI agents might have actually been the
organizers of the January six riots.
If you have evidence, I want to see it and
bring it to me.
And I will be the first to say, look, we have
evidence of that.
No evidence.
This is now going on multiple nights on Fox
News and not a shred of evidence has actually
been presented.
We'll have more on this on the show Instagram
page.
Follow us on Instagram at David Pakman show